[Applause]
the euro is two currencies what tinder
is taps everybody loves to criticize it
but at the end of the day a lot of
people you wouldn't expect to use it
totally do I'm sure many of you have
heard economists and experts of all
kinds making predictions about the end
of the single European currency the best
thing Germany could do for Europe is to
quit the single currency but it won't
Larry Elliott for the Guardian euro is a
patently flawed construct which its
architects knew at the time of its
creation George Soros nevertheless the
reality is way different in fact the
euro is the second most common worldwide
reserve currency and at the end of the
video today you're gonna see how it
might not be far from being the first at
this point you might be thinking but the
US dollars first there's absolutely no
way that's going anywhere but maybe I'm
right look one third of international
trade uses the euro as its exchange
currency 20% of the reserve currencies
from central banks are denominated in
Euros and many other countries also
issued debt in this currency
but this is not the end of the story if
you follow visual politic every week you
already know that Donald Trump is
putting lots of tariffs on international
trade so what does that mean well think
about it if Americans are going to buy
less stuff abroad there will be fewer
dollars in circulation and then you've
got to think about who's signing free
trade deals with seemingly everyone and
of course that's the European Union
they've already passed a treaty with
Canada the so called cita but this is
not the only one in the last two years
Europe has reduced tariffs with Japan
Mexico and many other countries
in other words the more Europeans buy
abroad the more euros there will be in
circulation this means there could be a
moment where instead of having one
hegemonic reserve currency we might have
to the US dollar and the euro so I can
probably guess what you're thinking
right now I mean what good does this
really do anyone is it actually useful
for the Europeans to have the euro as
the hegemonic currency well yeah and at
the same time know if you're watching
this from you country and you have a
company well having the Euro as the
world's reserve currency it's not going
to help you very much
[Music]
but if you're working for a European
governments boy you're probably feeling
really lucky if there's a big demand for
euros the European Central Bank will
have a bigger margins of prints money
without valuing it anyway we actually
talked about this in our video about the
dollar if you haven't seen that one yet
you'll find a link in the description
below check it out after watching this
one now the big question is why is the
euro more popular than any other
currency for example why the Euro and
why not the Chinese yuan and why are so
many economists critical of the euro
well today we're going to answer these
questions but before we do as we always
do let's take a look back at the history
[Music]
substantial crisis during the 70s
European countries were happy to trade
with each other although there is no
European Union back then there was
something very similar and that was the
common market nonetheless there was a
problem each country had its own
national currency and each currency
works in a different way for example the
German market was strong and stable but
the Italian lira was devaluing every
other day imagine a situation you work
in a German bank and you lend a million
liras to an Italian company at the
moment that you lender two million liras
is worth a thousand German marks but
when it's time for that Italian company
to give you the money back the lira has
been devalued so even if you get the
million liras back when you exchange to
your local currency you only get about
900 German marks not exactly business
brilliance
all right so in order to avoid this
European politicians they met together
in a room and I'm really not making this
up
apparently they decided to try something
called the snake in the tunnel
so here the snake is kind of a metaphor
for currency fluctuations because
currencies go up and down like
apparently a snake goes up and down so
if you don't want the snake to go crazy
you make a tunnel and put the snake in
the tunnel that way the currency doesn't
fluctuate look the only possible excuse
for this sort of analogy was that it was
the 1970s Bob Marley was alive
bell-bottoms were trendy it was just a
really different time
[Music]
all right so importantly did this snake
in the tunnel agreement work well no it
didn't during the 1980s European
currencies went up and down like drunk
snake in a very wide tunnel trying to
continue that terrible 70s metaphor this
is why decades later European
politicians met again in another room
this time it was 1992 and they had moved
on from the ridiculous names of the
1970s and they decided to call it the
Maastricht Treaty and in this one they
got really serious and said let's not
Corral with any more snakes and any more
tunnels that was weird it was the 70s
let's just let's make a currency that
everyone can use there'll be no more
exchange rates there'll be no more
fluctuations that we know more
that we had to deal with before
all right everyone sound good and then
essentially Great Britain puts ads up
and is like guys I don't I don't I don't
want in with that I really like my pound
sterling and everyone else in the room
was basically Geiger yourself for doing
this anyway and this is how a three-step
process to create a single currency
started
[Music]
in 1999 all the EU stock market started
listing in euros and later on European
citizens started using the new coins for
their daily trades today we've all
gotten used to hearing about the euro
like any other normal currency but make
no mistake back then it was an
unprecedented financial experiment and
this is how the first critics came to be
[Music]
Europe exemplifies a situation
unfavorable to a common currency it is
composed of separate nations speaking
different languages with different
customs and having citizens feeling far
greater loyalty and attachment to their
own country than to a common market or
to the idea of Europe Milton Friedman
and I might one's a what's the problem
we're the single currency and that's
easy if we have a single currency that
German bank we talked about before we'll
have no problem sending money to an
Italian or a Greek company so well what
happens then well since there's no
currency risk German banks you have a
lot of money lend it to poorer Italian
Greek and Spanish companies all of a
sudden rich countries have started to
invest in poor countries like there is
no tomorrow and yeah yeah I can probably
guess what you're thinking right now
what's the problem with all of this it
sounds pretty great well the problem
comes with the crisis
[Music]
banks must take bigger losses on Greek
loans says German Finance Minister
basically the southern European
economies they're poorer and no weaker
when there's a crisis their companies
are the first ones to go bankrupt so if
companies can't pay their debts back the
banks can go bankrupt too and this is
what we call the risk of contagion
this explains why during the 2008 crisis
so many politicians and economists
suggested abandoning the Euro many of
them talked about the creation of two
different euros one for the wealthy
countries who are solid and stable and
another kind of shitty euro for the
poorer countries and that kind of weaker
euro that just be happy to devaluate as
they want nonetheless today the euro
it's still alive and kicking and it
wasn't split into two different parts so
why was this well let's roll into the
next section
[Music]
long live the chaos critics are right
the European Central Bank also known as
the ECB is a modern-day Tower of Babel
it works similarly to a country's
government the current presidents is a
man named Mario Draghi and the Executive
Board is something like the executive
power but there's also a legislative
power and that's the Governing Council
this is where you have representatives
from all of the eurozone countries this
one from Spain this one from France
Germany Slovenia well all the countries
that have the euro as their currency
these guys they're the real decision
makers they decide whether to raise or
lower interest rates or prints more or
less money but before they do they have
to reach an agreement and this is where
the problems really start the southern
European countries they want to print
more money but their northern neighbors
they don't since they can't come to an
agreement it's almost impossible to make
drastic decisions
[Music]
now this is all true and the problem is
well I actually where is the problem I
mean where is the problem in having a
currency that cannot be devalued because
those who are in charge of printing us
don't agree with each other I mean isn't
this actually a strength we've talked
about this hundreds of times on visual
politic the best currency is the
strongest one if the value of your money
doesn't change there is low inflation
and you can do your shopping without
being afraid of losing all your money
you could also if you wanted start a
tech company because you know you can
invest long term so now you might be
wondering well Simon is the Euro
actually that's stable well have a look
at this chart
[Music]
here you can see a comparison between
the monetary supply the so-called m2 of
the ECB and the American Federal Reserve
can you see how they go handing out in
less than twenty years the euro has
become as solid as the American dollar
in fact Europeans have already forgotten
what inflation even is for a better
understanding the American Federal
Reserve has two main goals keeping
inflation low and keeping unemployment
low as well the European Central Bank
instead has just one goal on their
agenda and that's monetary stability and
so far while they've achieved it so yeah
we can say that the euro is as solid and
abundant as the US dollar but question
is now could it be even more solid and
even more abundant and the short answer
is yeah today the eurozone has around
320 million inhabitants that's almost
the same as the United States but
despite the European economy being
smaller than the American one the
eurozone can increase as long as new
countries join it
[Music]
in the last ten years six new countries
have adopted the euro as their currency
and despite the fact that the political
climate is not currently very much in
favor of it Poland or the Nordic
countries might end up joining the Euro
at some point as well this wasn't enough
there are many other currencies that are
linked to the euro remember in a
previous video we talked about French
colonies in Africa in their video we
said how countries like the Ivory Coast
and Senegal have a common currency
called the CFA franc this currency is
actually linked to the euro and we're
talking about more than a hundred and
fifty million people in emerging
economies here in other words with so
many people using euros in their daily
lives there are enough coins out there
to make it easy for any company to get
their hands on them and so now you might
be thinking well yes I mean a lot of
people do use the euro no doubt but you
know who else has a lot of users the
Chinese yuan this currency is also known
as the renminbi and it's becoming more
and more fashionable these days well so
why are we using euros instead of
renminbi
well let's have a look shall we
[Music]
the flaws of the UN well you're
absolutely right China is full of a lot
of people who are using this currency
for their daily transactions this means
high demand for this currency and lots
of notes and lots of coins and
circulation at first glance there should
be enough for the yuan to become an
international reserve currency but there
is a problem
China puts 15,000 United States dollars
annual personal cap on overseas bank
card withdrawals yeah yeah they're right
China does not want Yuans to leave the
country this is why they put lots of
capital controls in place in other words
finding you'ens in the international
markets it's not an easy job in fact
China wants to avoid Chinese businessman
taking money out of the country
hence the Chinese People's Bank has lots
and lots of restrictions and as you can
imagine in a dictatorship like the
Chinese one it's hard to believe in the
independence of their central bank in
other words if XI Jingping needed to he
could simply change the rules and just
stop printing as much money as he wants
it
[Music]
don't believe me well do you really
think a political system doesn't affect
a currency if you do you should probably
watch our video on Turkey there you'll
see what happens when you mix
authoritarianism and economic crisis and
it's not good for now though it's your
turn
do you think the euro can become as
important as the dollar or maybe we see
a brand new crisis destroying the
European single currency please leave
your answer in the comment section below
and also visit the reconsider media web
site they are the podcast that provided
the vocals in this episode that were not
mine and don't forget we publish brand
new videos every week so hit that
subscribe button and click the bell icon
so you'll always receive a notification
when we publish a new video and if you
liked this episode give it a thumbs up
share it with your friends as always
I'll see you in the next episode and if
you want to learn more about politics
and hear even more of my lovely voice
you can join us at reconsider media we
have a podcast at reconsidered Mediacom
slash podcast see you there
[Music]